wheel of fortune fans though are also up
in arms after a contestant missed out on
a trip to puerto rico due to a small
technicality take a look
chris it's your turn i'm gonna solve
yeah a frozen concoction frozen
concoction no you know what we uh can't
accept that carol it's your turn frozen
concoction yeah that's it
[Music]
chris knows what he did which is why he
went back he threw in that article he
threw in the a in front of it and we
can't accept that just the way that
we're just one of the rules and we got
to go by him and carol ends up getting
the trip to puerto rico
oh carol um i okay so
i thought he just was like uh frozen
concoction no he said it like a frozen
concoction
didn't he i maybe he did but i heard a
frozen concoction
but even that's close though i mean it's
an i get it as the rules go you can't
say i have frozen concoction but it kind
of was like a bit of can we don't have
time to replay that do we i have to
we're playing it now we can't can we do
can we break this the final we need
chris it's your turn i'm going to solve
yeah a frozen concoction no he says he
says
pat has a very good ear if he caught
that like that whereas you and i were
like did he say uh pat might have been
doing this for a while i think he might
he might know his stuff it's true but a
rule is a rule i know people are mad
about it though a little bit i guess so
yeah i mean the rules are rules i as a
as a viewer i'd be like oh that doesn't
seem fair but it is we got people here
talking about it too you know jk says
totally fair it's part of the rules yeah
affiliate says i didn't even hear the
mistake which is why we played it again
um venice says totally
fair and you know what i
i'm on board i just do feel like it just
sting a bit you can see it in his face
like it really stings that he was that
close but that's his fault it is it is
totally in the most loving way yeah it
was his fault yeah